from an American perspective I would say
is it given the competing nature of
interests
is it in the top tier of interests to
prevent Russian expansion in Eastern
Europe it's not something you'd wish you
want free people to live in Freedom on
the other hand the freedom of people
threatened the world over their ongoing
border disputes in Africa the continent
that I'm actually interested in that
have been grinding on causing the deaths
of literally millions for decades and
you know that's sad nobody wants it to
be the case but is it in our interest to
physically prevent it or try to we also
have a terrible record of actually
affecting the desired outcomes we just
withdrew from Afghanistan after the
longest war in American history and
rather than pausing to ask why didn't
that go as expected what are the
mistakes we made what are the
assumptions that led to those mistakes
were on to you know contemplating an
invasion of Russia during winter because
that works